mal kommt und wenn man in new york ist
da muss man natürlich gucken oder
phantom kommt am besten bei ihm zu hause
trifft aber ich habe es gerade gehört
der ist ganz zu hause der ist gerade
außer häufig unterwegs so ein bisschen
seriöse berichterstattung machen
ich bin hier auf der fifth avenue und
egal was die schlauberger
presseschreiben hier nennt wenige
blogger stefan niggemeier behauptete
dass irgendwo der premium komponenten
mario barth ist der wiederum behauptet
dass mit ingo in welcher hand die drum
und dran
ausgewiesen amerika gestorben und
deswegen gleich wie das mit dem er aus
wie amerika trick nur um geld bitten
[Musik]
willkommen in volume heute perle der
ostküste einige vergleichen zweiten
städten die bei brandenburg oder an
leverkusen
obwohl fand unrecht und bat ihn kennt
man zum beispiel aus der valascia
wollten haben sie also unbedingt film
schicken und reichsten städten sowie der
amerikanische studie teilt haben jetzt
mit seinen werken nach vorne bringen
will
jeder seine kompletten erbeuten erfahren
und da ist es schöner machen laut
hofmann zwiebel sterben für eine
straftat